yarattığını ele aldı evlerin merkezinde
yer aldı
değil mi diye tahmin ettim Evren
sonra
Hayaller
Bir Hayal kırıklığına bir boş vermişti
sebebiyet ver
iyoruz
olay nedir bu iki defa indir
mesi ve
topernik
ticareti
evrenin Merkezi dünya değil
benim Güneş
dahil oldu Dünyanın etrafında dönmüyor
ve bütün hepsi
ortaya çıkıyor ki tüm ortaya çıkarıyor
Dünya
Güneş'in etrafında dönüyor Yani bir
insansın ki
Hello Fatih'te tasar
ımı şöyle yavaş yavaş etkiliyor
kitleleri
Hani özene bezene yer seç
ildiği bizim mekanını
falan
suretinden ötede öteye toprak ve sudan
yaratıl
dığını o 19 yüzyılda belki biliyorsunuz
bu
mekansal incitmeden inanılmaz tüm
şekilde bir iyileşmeye
gelebilir Evet
bu hal Eksen kavramın suresinden
yaratılışını baş harfiyle
son model
di
[Müzik]
bireyi tanıyoruz ya modernat
ifler ne diyor komik o Ergo
o ayakları asla o eğer o uzun böyle
inanılmaz bir süpere o ve İdil'in
savaşından meydana gelen bir kompozisyon
oğlu ne yapmak zorunda insan
bedenimizde kendi elimizle değil
iz O içiracı var bu sebep
le var Bir bedende neye görünüyor Bu
enteg
re olup parçaya bölüyoruz değil mi Kim
daha
kim Galip gelecek diye bir
şey
Aslında Ümit falan
gibi Ne o ortaya çıktı iki milyon yıllık
bir ağırlığı
hava oldu
Yok oldu hani bütün hayaller mahvoldu
beyaz atlı prens yokmuş gibi yürekten
tatsız bir uyarı
dürüstlüğün zaman
nasıl hoş beğen kişiye
cahilliğe gündüzü
maden arabalarını gösteren insan değil
Madem bu dünya
adet zaten iş parçaya bölünmüş
Dünya Savaşı
yılından birisi o da savaş
larda Orkun bireyle
ve Almanya'ya
değeri
polidi
bu Cehennem nasıl
cevap verene kadar
ne yapıyor insanlık
cahillik de
Almanya'da Almanya tutar insan nasıl
bahseder içinde imha ile ilgili
değildi dünya tarihinde ilk bilim adamı
Home olmak üzere
uygulamaya
Neyi anlat
tık görüyorsunuz
mikroda makro'ya dişli ne anlatıyorum
bile
önce Tanrı dünyayı yarattı
toplumsal heplerdi kutsal biçimimizi ve
dünya dahil Dünya cennet gibi
hayal kırıklığına bilimin ve
aydınlanmanın geliştirildiği gibi
kullan
abilirsen
evlere
Yani öyle bir mekâ
nında
[Müzik]
sıradan olarak addettiğimiz unsuru
Merkezi gözümüzü Ermeni
gibidir bakıyoruz çok ilginç bir durumda
ne demektir
dünyada
aidatı daha az bilinen
[Müzik]
önemli konuların
emeklerini aşaması da olduğu için
Okyanus akıntılar
değiştirildiği zaman yavaşladığı zaman
durduğu zaman
fakat dünya gibi dört beş sen
Elik
bir yağmur yağarken ama
onlar öyle tavsiye etmesinden
Araştırmalar ve hormonlar yapılabilmesi
gerekiyor
ki istikrar Yok öyle bir
bilgisayar koskocaman
halkı büyüklüğünde ve bulunduğu şehrin
elektriğini yani
tüketici
ve soğuk
Akın endonez ekonomi
sine başladığı
zaman şimdi öyle deniyor
o bulutlar bu taraf var alışkın olduğu
için çok önemli olan
yavaşlıyor Şimdi gaz yavaşlaması sıcak
diye soğuktur ve yavaşlaması ne anlama
geliyor biliyor musunuz yavaşladığınız
zaman
Norveç için değil
çok çok daha Güney değil de Çünkü yok
derin sulara
konusunda daha çok
bilindik bu
Bununla ilgili ben kendimi bildim
ama
bir yaka pirince giderken evdeki okulda
olmamamız
gerekiyor bütün dünyada inanılmaz bir
çağ ay ile ilgili evren ile ilgili
yaşadabilir mekanlar bulmakla ilgili
bunu
[Müzik]
anlamını
söylüyoruz dünyanın ne yapıyor yavrum
dünyayı nasıl görüyoruz
o telefonda dünyanın 10 milyara geliyor
bu 10 milyar nasıl bes insanlar nasıl
temiz suya kavuşacak bütün
ölçülür kalk diye indirip korkunç açık
olan tautil olan ve hesaplanabilirliği
10 derece
Şu hale geldi
bu çok önemli
hepinizin O büyük
Ben kendileri
bilimselliğe
insaniyetinden hiçbir
şey ama o bile ona bile
2000 yıllık bakıyor ki
böyle bir hale getirmiş ölmeden
önce hep kelâ
bütün bu hayal kırıklığı ve o bakıcısı
yer
den kıyıya
yükselen öykülerle
aşmanın Veba ve Özlem mi bakmanız mübahı
Aslında Yakından bak
tığı bilim Naza uzay araştırmaları kara
delikler nötron Yıldızlara bütün bu
araştırmalara harcanan
paralara bütün dünya var
olduğunu görüyorum
baktığımız zaman
evrene duyduğumuz o garip yüzünüzü
arkasında ne saklı bir yarım saattir
söylüyorum
ne yapamıyoruz kendimizi
gerçekleştir
dik ne tatlı bir Neslihan yapıyor böyle
baktığın zaman gökyüzünde Tabii ki
cennet sah
[Müzik]
tanıdıklarımdan birbirleri
siyah beyaz beyaz
bu olaylar devreye giriyor tüm yapısı
Bugünler
hanımefendi
oluşturarak konuyu gibi ifade
oluşturarak belirlenebilme
çünkü
göndermeni bilen
[Müzik]
%99.99 veriyor
sırf karanlık madde taş ve gaz
bu kadar onda 0.0
[Müzik]
evrende hep kendi valiler
olan Dünyamız
karşımıza çıkıyor o yüzden artık
bakışlarını ilahi
şey yapmamız lazım toprağı temiz
tutmamız lazım delillerimizi
lazım tabii ki gençler
size burada çok çok büyük görevler
düşüyor Biz sizi anneleriniz
babalarınızı olarak maalesef tam
tersi olarak tarihe baktık ki
komedi ile birlikte dünyayı bile Dünya
Ukrayna ile ilgili arkayı davranış kal
ıpları bulunan
barajları yıkabiliyor ben tabi bu
bağlantı özellikle Tuvaletler gibi
bölgesindeki
termik santralleri nükleer santralleri
hatırlamak istiyorum İlla Bizim Dünyamız
için toplantıya
kadar Bunlar dünyanın için büyük bir
dünya şu an bilinen evlerde en büyük
mucize bu mucizenin değerini bilmek
zorundayız bilmek zorundasınız teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]